have you heard of this thing called ged
match
no what was that oh have you heard of
the golden state killer
no okay so
in the 1970s there was that's what they
call you
yeah that was my nickname in high school
golden state killer uh in the in the
1960s 70s and i think 80s there was this
guy who basically like raped like 50
women and then he murdered eventually
like 20 of like he was a serial killer
and uh he got away with it for years no
one knew who it was and patton oswalt's
wife pat oswald the comedian his wife
who recently died right before she died
published her like master work or life's
work and it was about the golden state
killer and how he's never got been
caught and it renewed interest and then
the fbi got all into it because all the
press and they eventually use this
website called ge it's public
it's like anyone can use it it's like an
open source website and it analyzes all
of the uh
information from 23andme ancestry and
like all that stuff all the
database stuff and they found they put
his dna the golden state killer's dna
which they had into this ged match thing
and they realized that the daughter of
the killer or like they're like well
this is so aligned it must be like the
daughter or the granddaughter of the
killer recently signed up for 23 and me
and so they stake out this guy's house
they dig through his garbage they find
they go boom got him and that's how they
arrest him and they arrested him when he
was like
and if you google golden state killer
you'll see like these pictures of this
old man and they got him because he got
away with it for so long but eventually
they brought him to justice and
now
they've caught many dozens maybe even
hundreds of killers or rapists this way
which is good
but
it's kind of scary and so you could so i
was gonna say so you're you're worried
about this why why is this working
because it's being used for grandpa and
trouble it's being used for good now
but
like
you could see like do i want to be in
the state do i want to be in this
database and so this is one thing i'm a
bit worried about so you can go to ged
match and you can upload your results
and it can tell you all types of stuff
about your results you can see a lot of
interesting stuff and you could like if
you can somehow get the dna from an fbi
case which i believe in some cases you
can you can like upload it and there's
like
thousands of like these internet
detectives using this database to solve
crimes it's kind of fascinating it's
kind of interesting and it's definitely
a little scary
wow is there like a subreddit for these
uh you know like sort of like public
crime solvers yes there is and it's very
very interesting and most of the time
they're wrong so like if you remember
when the boston like the boston uh
marathon bombing they like named like
these like three guys and they they kind
of [__] with these guys lives they
they didn't end up doing it but everyone
was certain on that subreddit and
they're uploading pictures and they go
this guy works at this place it wasn't
them they were wrong no one guessed it
that it was the two actual guys but this
is a little bit different because it's
dna but dna isn't perfect so it's like
there's a it'll say like there's a um
this person is five percent related to
this person so it's like all right let's
see what that is that could be like a
distant cousin until you like track your
way down to that and you build these
family trees to figure out oh you know
it's kind of weird that like this
matches this person and they're they
also lived in the same area and so it's
not perfect but it's like pretty good so
anyway i thought that's why i may not
get 23 in me
[Laughter]
yeah i also know people who have gotten
it and realized like their dad is not
their real dad um and i think that that
happened to a family member i think
that's a you know
uh you know side effect to be aware of
sometimes ignorance is a family member
of mine
a family member of mine found out that
their parent had a base their parent
cheated on the spouse and had a a
a kid
and so they logged on and they go oh man
i've got a second brother around you
know like a stepbrother or a half
brother
and uh it changes [__] i was gonna say
without getting too personal that that
uh that has like that they went public
with it or they just kind of kept that
information to themselves no no no they
did not go public with it but it like
was very it was i don't know they
haven't talked about it with me too much
but it was it seems like it was like
somewhat earth shattering yeah there's a
there's a thing that i've heard that
goes on which is um people who
uh
people who use sperm banks so like a
sperm donor
will take the t
sorry people who didn't realize
that their parent had used a sperm donor
or whatever they will get the sequencing
done or whatever and they'll find out
like oh my god i have 42 like half
brothers or sisters out there it's like
oh yeah this was a person who
um
you know this is a person who donated a
bunch and then so yeah you actually do
genetically share with all these
different people
um like wow that's really crazy so
there's all kinds of like interesting
stuff and i think 23andme
their business model is to sell your
data right like i think that is the core
business model as they sell
pharmaceutical companies
for um
you know like the research or whatever
like i don't know if it's [__] up or
if it's like this is for the good of
science but i don't think you
really know or opt it's not clear that
hey like it's not clear yeah it's
probably it's definitely the terms you
know but nobody's reading the terms and
so that's the problem it's like
it's like a benevolent dictator it's
like it's cool when they're making the
trains run on time it's not cool when
they start killing people
you know what i mean
yeah it's like it's good when it's good
and then but it could go bad really easy